Salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche, et le dimanche c'est le jour des explications !
et je vais vous apprendre la technique ultime pour faire disparaitre un briquet !
Ce petit objet qu'on a tous pour allumer des bougies d'anniversaire, ou de l'encen...
Ou encore pour faire une jolie flamme, si vous êtes à un concert ou à un spectacle, et que surtout vous regardez cette vidéo dans les années 1990...
Je vais donc vous apprendre à faire disparaître ce petit objet et aussi comment se servir de n'importe quel objet comme d'un briquet.
C'est un tour qui peut se faire les manches remontées, alors vous remontez vos manches et ensuite...
[tic]
Vous faites disparaître complètement le briquet !
Le seul problème, c'est que je n'avais pas vérifié avant, et...
[tic]
et il ne marche pas...
Ce qui est tout à fait normal pour un rouleau de scotch !
En effet, c'est très rare qu'un rouleau de scotch fasse du feu.
Vous l'avez surement compris à ce stade de la vidéo, c'est un tour de magie qui fonctionne en deux temps.
Il y a d'abord un détournement d'attention et il y a une illusion !
Pour être honnête avec vous, je me suis servi du cadre de la caméra pour lâcher le briquet,
quand ma main commençait à sortir du champ.
Vous aussi vous pouvez faire exactement ça, quand vous êtes assis à une table, en le faisant tomber sur vos genoux.
Et tout le reste de l'illusion vient de ce stylo.
[tic]
C'est un stylo particulier, puisqu'il fait briquet.
Mais un briquet, évidemment qui ne marche pas.
Et oui, voilà c'est ça toute l'illusion du tour. Il faut donner l'illusion sonore, pour faire croire que vous avez un briquet.
C'est l'illusion auditive. Je vais vous apprendre à faire ça.
Je préfère vous prévenir, vous allez avoir la sensation d'avoir un super pouvoir et vous voudrez tout transformer en briquet.
Vous allez coller votre langue derrière vos dents supérieures... comme ça.
C'est une vidéo où j'ai l'air très intelligent...
La langue est complètement collée contre les dents et légèrement contre le palais.
Et vous allez retirer la langue très rapidement dans une succion.
[tic]
Ça donne l'illusion d'un bruit un peu métallique.
Il faut le faire le plus rapidement possible. Quand je dis rapidement ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut faire...
[tic]
Il ne faut pas le faire très rapidement.
Il faut surtout décoller rapidement.
Évitez de faire un bruit trop lent, il faut faire un bruit sec et rapide.
Déjà ça fonctionne très bien comme ça, mais si en plus vous placez votre main comme si vous aviez un briquet, et l'autre main qui protégerait du vent,
ça va créer une petite caisse de résonance, qui va amplifier l'illusion de bruit métallique.
[tic]
Et avec ça, tout peut se transformer en briquet.
Même un dé !
Dans les trucs marrants à faire, il y a donc  le fait de faire disparaître le briquet, de faire semblant de l'avoir et de faire le bruit pour donner l'illusion qu'il disparaît.
Vous pouvez aussi faire bugger le cerveau des gens en prenant le briquet à l'envers et en disant...
"il ne marche pas ton briquet !"
Je peux vous dire que c'est très drôle, parce que vous faites appel à la logique de la personne, vous avez le briquet à l'envers, ça ne fonctionne pas, c'est logique.
Et en même temps il sentira qu'il y a un bug, quelque chose qui n'est pas normal.
Et ce qui n'est pas normal, c'est évidemment d'avoir entendu le bruit du briquet, alors qu'il était à l'envers.
Je pense que vous allez vous éclater tout votre dimanche et pendant toute votre semaine avec ce tour.
Si en regardant cette vidéo vous avez fait "tic, tic, tic", devant l'écran tout en continuant de regarder la vidéo,
vous pouvez me le faire savoir en laissant un petit pouce en l'air !
N'hésitez pas à commenter sous la vidéo, dans le descriptif il y a tous les réseaux sociaux, où l'on peut se retrouver.
Pensez à vous abonner à la chaîne. Hier je vous est donné le nouveau défi,
et ce que j'allais faire à l'issu de ce défi.
Si vous n'avez pas suivi, regardez la vidéo numéro 100.
Prenez soin de vous, profitez de ce dimanche, et rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain MentalVlog.
Ciao !